نحن نسير نحو الخطوط
الأمامية ويمكنك أن ترى أنه لا يوجد مكان
للاحتماء هنا ، لقد رأينا للتو
صاروخًا صادرًا يتجه
نحو الموقع الروسي ، لكن
عليك دائمًا القلق بشأن ما يعود
علينا مررنا ببقايا روسية
تفجير شاحنة عسكرية إلى نائب
قائد الحداد نزار من اللواء الآلي 63 التابع للجيش الأوكراني ،
نحن
عالقون
هذا ما يحدث للروس عندما يخطوون على أرضي
الأوكرانية العزيزة ،
ننتقل إلى مواقع القوات التي
قيل لنا أن نسرع ​​في هذا المشهد.
يبدو الأمر الذي لا يرحم وكأننا في
غابة ولكن هذا ما يبدو عليه هذا الجزء من
منطقة ميكولايف في أوكرانيا
من طائرة بدون طيار وخط رفيع من الأشجار
الغطاء الوحيد حولنا
نحن الآن في الخندق حيث
تجاوز الروس هذه الكاميرا
للتو.  بعد هذه المنطقة على الجانب الآخر من
حقل ضخم
في هذه اللحظة ، أخبرنا أننا على بعد
كيلومترين فقط أقل من ميل
ونصف من القوات الروسية
على طول خط الأشجار هذا ، هناك موقع روسي
الأيونات ، العدو هناك يشير إلى
مواقعهم
التي يراقبها الجنود دائمًا من
الأرض وأحيانًا من طائراتهم بدون طيار في
الهواء عندما يرون هدفهم الروسي
يصيبون
إصابة مباشرة بمركبة روسية ثم
انفجار ثانٍ من أي اصطياد.
نيران بداخلها لكن روسيا لديها
مدفعيتها وطائراتها بدون طيار أيضًا ،
وهو أضعف صوت يرسل
نائب القائد وجنديه مرة أخرى
تحت غطاء
مدى وحشية هذه المعركة على
خط
المواجهة ، حيث يستخدم الروس
مدفعية صواريخ المدفعية التقليدية
وهم يعملون فوق الخنادق  مع
وحداتي قاموا بقصف مستوطنات للمدنيين
أيضًا الذين لم يفعلوا أي شيء لهم.
ما كان أسوأ يوم لك في
هذه الخنادق أصابت أربعة جنود قتلوا في
ضربة واحدة كانت قواته تقاتل
هنا لفترة طويلة ولكن إلى متى يتم
تصنيفها
ما الذي تسمعه وتتعامل معه
كل يوم تقريبًا
ولكن بابلو البالغ من العمر 26 عامًا يقول على الأقل إنه
مع عائلته حرفيًا  s هو
والده يارسولوف البالغ من العمر 59
عامًا وأخيه نزار البالغ من العمر 34 عامًا ،
فأنت أب
لديك ولدان معك هنا ولداك ،
ما يشبه القتال معًا
بسيطًا جدًا وبسيط جدًا
بالنسبة لهما ، الحياة الخندق أسهل
لأنهما '  إعادة القتال من أجل بعضنا البعض
ماذا تقول والدتهم
عنكم جميعًا تقاتلون معًا هنا في
هذا المكان الأكثر خطورة
[ضحك]
إنها متوترة
أيضًا
تشعر زوجاتنا وأطفالنا بالقلق من أن
يشارك جندي مقطع الفيديو الخاص به
لإطلاق النار الروسي الجديد  يمكن للعين المجردة أن تكتشف بسهولة
مكان سقوطها
عندما كنت على مسافة تزيد قليلاً عن ميل من
خط المواجهة عندما نكون في العراء
عندما نكون في العراء ، وعلينا
الركض
هنا ، فأنت قريب بما يكفي ليتم
قتلك بنيران الأسلحة  ليس مجرد قصف من دبابة
سارة سيدنر في منطقة ميكولايو بأوكرانيا